we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk
[Music]
hey folks this is it we
might be drunk here we are it's a it's a
late night at the the gotham studios
sam's repping the uh the team straight
from the garden
actually that's not true i went to the
cellar for two sets and straight here
wow that's a great night great night
knicks game seller seller
pod could have been better we lost ah
but the playoff energy man was special
it was that's what new york's all about
it felt
there was a dude i'm in the nosebleeds
with my boy john weisberg
when the nose bleeds a dude is blowing
rails
right next to us shut up he's just doing
coke right next what and he goes you
want some i'm like i'm good
and it was like a tough thing where he
he's like i was like i got to work later
he's like what do you do i'm like [ __ ]
uh it's like right after dude took a
picture with me at the games i'm like
i'm a comedian
and he's just like where do you work and
i'm just like uh you know all over
he's like we're going the cellar i'm
like i'm like yeah i work the cell i'm
going there later he's like can i
he said can i come with you no way i
just watch you do coke you're gonna be
my plus one to work
yeah right also you never tell people
your comic and this guy's coked up
yeah i don't know why i did it i was
just kind of like i get it i messed
up well the worst is when you're got
like the uber driver or whatever and
he's like what do you do and you're like
uh my accountant and he's like oh yeah
what kind of projects are you working
on what kind of accounting you do i'm
like civil
i don't know i don't know i don't know
anything about accounting i don't know
why i picked it
yeah you got to pick you got to pick a
lie you know a couple lines on it i know
i should have said furniture mover
or you know palestinian army something
where you just
get some sympathy yeah exactly get out
of it how
let's can we do the oh yeah yeah sorry
you're being all mysterious with the
booze as we get a brown paper bag got a
big bottle of hooch
now uh we weekly we we trade off you
bring one week i bring the next
i like this yeah i like it too this uh i
wanted to cover because it's such a
special bottle
and i rarely break it out maybe a
christmas or a thanksgiving
so i'm pulling out tonight folks all the
stops
old english oh oh my god
this is hot stuff lagerville and 16.
look at you 16 years the epstein
i wish i wish he went 16. that might
that might have been legal in some
states oh yeah good point
all right although still gross yes don't
uh we don't condone it
see the ice melted just enough you get
just a cut of water
that's a pd scotch right here oh yeah
this is exciting
very exciting schumer used to have this
in the green room that's where i learned
about it
oh it's like bacon no it is like baking
it's so smoky
oh that's [ __ ] perfect oh
it goes down easy that is good ass
scotch man this will get you to relapse
that is good stuff i remember i did i
shot a thing on comedy central once like
years ago
uh in new orleans and it was a bunch of
comics with a showcase for their show
and this one comic was like he was like
i'm probably not gonna drink this week
and i was like a young comic
it's new orleans you're not going to
drink you know i don't know it's been
like 30 days i didn't realize he had a
problem
so i'm like pushing him like come on not
in a way like if he told me he's an
addict
right but he was like no it's been 30
days i thought he was just like taking
some time off
yeah literally before he goes on stage
he was like i see him with a beer he's
like stumbling i'm like uh this might be
my fault oh
the rest of the week it got to a point
where he was like pulling the comedy
central exercise did you get a [ __ ]
problem with me
you gotta [ __ ] we're at dinner
afterwards it was me
him and some comedy comedy central
exactly you know who are really cool
yeah and he's like how come i haven't
gotten a half hour special yet
oh and i'm just like oh boy then he's
like he's just starting starting [ __ ]
with me it was one of the things where
i'm like this dude
i think i know who it is now yeah yeah
you're painting a picture here
wow i can't believe i felt going to bed
by the end because i was like at first
all these guys just being [ __ ] to me
all night but i was like
he might have burned some bridges this
week well
i didn't know you knew john panette but
wow man i think i know who it is now i
think i actually saw him tonight
but good guy great guy i think i don't
think he saw him tonight
okay i think he's got it under wraps uh
now if it's who i'm thinking i don't
think it's here no i don't think you'd
be able to guess either okay okay
well moving on yeah but yeah you gotta
admit though there was something fun
about a guy relapsing
for me maybe not perhaps for the friend
i'm sure that first drink is great
oh yeah i've seen a few guys relapse and
at the time it's kind of like yeah he's
doing it
yeah you know and you get all pumped up
i don't do that with the harder drugs
though they don't
put a needle in
yeah they just kind of go out you ever
thought about heroin
no i haven't the needle gets me thank
god it's a needle
you can you could freebase it can't you
ah i guess you're right well that's like
yeah i don't like any of these things i
don't snort anything
really you ever done blow never done it
i've never done it either there was a
kid when i was growing up in the city
who did who would always do coke and i
remember he was like a couple years
older than me
and he just did a bunch of blow and
jumped out of like a 30-story window
and i was like that's enough for me to
stick with this oh
man i also follow sports enough that i
do there were just enough stories of
like len
like len bias had a bad reaction there
was a daryl johnston guy there's enough
athletes i'm like if
i know they have like a bad reaction but
you look at a world-class athlete and
you're like yeah what chance do i have
right right exactly if they can't hang
but i know that's not how it works but
that's just how i
how i saw it why'd you never do it i
just didn't like the snorting
and uh i don't know i i don't really
need an upper i'm an energetic guy i
like to come down i like to relax
uh give me a give me a a shot or a beer
or something i don't i don't really want
to go up i'll do an adderall every now
and then
yeah if i'm you know adult drug yeah
crunch for time
when you're a kid you get [ __ ] up to
escape when you're adult you do drugs
you're like i guess i gotta focus
you know yeah yeah exactly yeah like
kids are
the adderall is just it's so prevalent
it's like every college
what's that kids do address i guess but
they're doing it for tests they're not
doing it to like party are they
ah i i did at the party really
oh yeah you know you want to keep
drinking and it kept you focused
while being drunk so you're like
loosey-goosey but still
in the pocket you know it's like that
seinfeld joke
focused and drunk seems like a terrible
combination yeah yeah you're just like
saying horrible [ __ ] and be like wow i
was present for all that
that's exactly what it is i took that
cop's gun and i saw every second of it
but yeah what was that sci-fi joke about
four loko
he's like you're trashed but alert right
you know or something like that
i feel like seinfeld gets so many shouts
out on this podcast
yeah well his bits are evergreen and uh
like
like uh memorable you know yeah for loka
what a [ __ ]
mess that was that just just get drunk
why do you have to like see that's the
thing that's young
person yes well like adults like we're
sipping a good ass scotch here
and i get it when you're young you're
not buying bottles like this but
you know but just getting [ __ ] up to
the point you can't even enjoy like
drink beer or something
yeah i know a bud light or a [ __ ]
white claw or whatever
i i did a couple four logos and it was
kind of like a badge of honor like how
crazy we are we go all the way but it's
it's that [ __ ] colorful can it's a
you know 24 ounce can
already already you're trash is it legal
oh yeah
okay but it was illegal for a minute it
was it was uh they
they let it go it was like you get a
bodega god damn
yeah crazy time what a country it's so
cool you brought a
log of you this is the nicest no one's
ever brought someone a log of one in a
brown paper bag like this
no one's ever had this shitty delivery
system for the best scotch
i know and i had to like walk around
with it it's been like look at this
[ __ ] idiot i want to be like no no
it's lockable
yeah that's just like coors light over
here
yeah you were uh you were in hartford
all weekend man that's it
it's getting good that club it really i
i hate to say it i've been trashing that
club for 20 years
and uh it was a full 180 fred was the
manager he killed it
yeah um he's out there every night with
a clipboard like taking notes looking at
the room what can be fixed he asked you
for
anything you didn't like tell me
critiques there's a bouncer in there
walking around because that's a heckle
room
yeah i've been that's the only club i've
ever been like attacked
at you got attacked well a guy charged
the stage and somebody stopped him thank
god but
uh it got pretty ugly
it was a front row three top and it was
a girl and two guys
and they kept [ __ ] with me like to
where only i could hear it
and no one else could hear because they
were right up on the stage so i'd be
like oh
i took an uber here and they're like
this guy takes uber what a loser you
know and i could hear it and they were
all giggling
what's wrong with uber i don't know but
it was just different tools everything i
said they would like
nitpick and joke about and insult me and
eventually i just snapped i was like
well you guys shut the [ __ ] up what's
your [ __ ] problem
and one guy was a little slow or off and
i was like you know i'm going all in on
the
special needs and the down syndrome and
all that and
one guy in the back goes hey leave him
alone
i'm like you're defending them they've
been heckling me all night he's like i
didn't hear a thing
oh no i'm battling this guy he's like a
boat shoe
white hair you know shirt open to here
and he's like leave them alone that
we're trying to enjoy a show and they
just paid for a show and you're going to
yell at them i'm like they've been
[ __ ] on me all night he's like i
didn't hear anything
so now they're like hey i'm like [ __ ]
you you're tired i'm going back and
forth
and then eventually they leave and i'm
just doing the thing where they're
walking out just let me see how many i
can get on this guy
and eventually i said virgin and the guy
went
running towards the stage and they they
got him but which means he was a virgin
exactly because if you say that he was
like a player he'd be like
that's not true yeah yeah exactly and uh
i
i was ready though i was like i could
take this guy because he was like this
kind of doughy
uh like short squirrely little you could
tell he lived at home because he wearing
his helmet though
he had that weird t-shirt where you
could tell it was like the neckline was
all
[ __ ] pulled out because you know he
like wipes [ __ ] on it or you you know
cleans his mouth you gotta you gotta get
a higher class of hecklers i know
this guy was bad news he was bottom of
the barrel but
uh but the problem is you went hard
yeah because that's it's almost like
sibling [ __ ] when you're a kid and your
little bro
and your older brother's like pinching
you under the table and
your parents don't see it but he keeps
pinching you and then just turn and go
[ __ ] you
and they go go to your room and you're
like you didn't see any of that that's
what they did to you
exactly yeah they nitpicked for at least
30 minutes and i just snapped
and i've been there i should have said
something throughout but yeah i snapped
on a guy and then uh
then [ __ ] donald sterling defends the
guy it's like come on man
donald sterling yeah it was like this
good looking rich guy i don't think
donald sterling is a handsome man
what oh wait are you thinking of roger
rogers sterling sorry sorry
you convinced the coolest madman
character with the racist
clippers owner who lost his team well i
got sterling yeah great there's a great
uh i think it was like a 30 for 30 type
dock
it's a podcast on donald sterling it's
great
really it's really good what's i mean
like his come like his rise or
what's the it's kind of like how he got
rich and he just [ __ ] he did a lot of
housing discrimination
a lot of shady ways he got rich then it
was you know weird with his wife it's
hilarious because
you know he's [ __ ] around on her with
like a much younger woman
but at the end they end they always end
up to get it's tough it's like
you knew who he was it's you're both
pretty old
what are you gonna be like what are you
gonna like get on bumble you're [ __ ]
in your 80s
right exactly exactly like bill gates
apparently it's come out that he was
like on the epstein plane
and he's uh is that true yeah i know
that he was i know that he was uh
like friendly with him but i don't i
didn't know that
i saw a report like melinda uh was
creeped out by him
yes yes and and he had a uh hall pass
with his ex
with with melinda no no bill had a hall
pass with his ex-girlfriend so
once a year he was allowed to see her
his ex-wife
yeah is that his ex-wife or
ex-girlfriend no she was he was married
they're getting
they got i think they started the
divorce in like 2019 which is like
that's what
when that kind of money's involved it
must take forever oh yeah
oh yeah but it's just so crazy this this
guy he looks like you know
he looks like such a dork but you know
money
somebody at an interesting point they
said the guys who look like that
probably are actually hornier
because they never got laid or something
you know you think like oh uh you know
uh
what's his face army hammer oh he's a
sex addict whatever but like that guy
can get laid in two seconds
but bill gates maybe is actually more
hungry for puss
well i think army hammer was more hungry
yeah that's true he liked the good rib
but yeah it's interesting like army
hammer could get laid probably more
easily like if we're at a bar
but just look at the power structure of
that company like you're such a
big like and people like shashi's
banging employees but it's like
what do you expect like he's in a
loveless marriage right he's the head
i'm not defending the guy but i'm just
saying like
where do you think he meets women what
do you think where do you think he like
has an edge exactly and ain't at the
nightclub no no
no no it's at the place where he's the
ceo
yeah what is clo chief something
something official i don't operating
chief operating officer
i don't know chief of operations ah
ceo he was yeah he's
it's a weird story man you see the
pictures of him and it's like just
it's hilarious and your post is just
posting pictures of him like
you're like his first single shot like
it's funny that he's like a celebrity
who's on the prowl
i know like they're treating him like
a-rod right well i mean he's a catch
you can't deny it he's a kid he's not a
hot guy but he's
you know one of the richest men in
america where where do you meet women if
not the workplace if you're at that
level
are there like billionaire dating apps
probably or millionaires i would guess
he's not on raya you know that'd be
hilarious to come across bill gates on
raya oh
just as it's just a window sound effect
it's taking everything i have not to
make a microsoft joke i'm sure that's
been done
oh i think i did one last week i think
we've both done them
it's it's right there for the taste
right you can help yourself
this is so this goes down so so easy so
good
maybe one of the best this is this is a
scotch right mm-hmm yeah
yeah single malt this is like one of
those uh i think it's like made in some
like
i don't know there's a bunch of scotches
like that i think it's yeah single malt
you said there's a lot of scotches that
are made and like
they have a certain smell that's so
peaty yeah like uh what's the
laphroaig fruit that's a good one
our bag is so good that's like the pds
that's a great scott
great scotch but it's not for everyone
i've had friends be like oh
it's a winter scotch i could do this in
the summer our bag is like a winter
that's true
uh oh i had something now i lost it
[ __ ] gay oh just like just like bill
gates
how was utah utah was great that club is
club wise guys in salt lake
one of the best clubs in the country
shout out to my my my man tan france
from queer i sent a bunch he wasn't he's
filming queer eye but he
sent a bunch of people from his uh he's
like his friends and people to come see
me
and he paid for their tickets i'm like
dude i would have come to your friends
well that's amazing he's like
he lives in a lot of cool people live in
salt lake salt lake's like kind of one
of these sleeper cool towns it's so cool
really devito and i went to like a
speakeasy bar
our first night there anthony devito's
with me great comic we haven't seen him
uh alex valuto uh was uh
hosting also terrific comic in salt lake
so we uh defeated i hit the speakeas who
getting great drinks just a great vibe
man
i love that that city's great great city
great people
and you know they got that dry bar thing
over there right that's
yeah yeah the the clean comedy special
the clean comedy specials so they're
we come out there and they're like oh
baby look at these new york
degenerates coming out here and and
slinging some you know crazy
crazy zingers and uh i think
they're so mormonized and [ __ ] and it's
so uh they don't drink coffee they don't
drink booze
i mean 15-minute walk they had a cup of
joe i was like god you're killing me
exactly yeah it's crazy there and it's
like it's a different culture but there
are a lot of
people that were raised mormon and now
are just like drunks it's like they it's
like they
they're so repressed yes it's like a rum
springer that lasted forever where
they're like i'm just gonna get [ __ ]
up forever
yeah and they over compensate so much
like hey here's all my tats i'm ripped i
got you know crazy hair
and i i my opener in salt lake was
always
every guy here looks like if monster
energy was a person oh my god
just buff and tattooed and pierced and
[ __ ]
so uh yeah there was like porn star-ish
people
oh my last show i'm like this is like a
porn star probably
yeah yeah yeah a lot of fake tits a lot
of like that
whitish blonde hair you know like cut
yes
yeah yeah they look like quicksilver or
something yeah
literally the best crowds are like i
i've been back on the road a bit it's
like
uh it's funny getting back on the road
like this i didn't have any experiences
like this but like i was at a club
recently and a guy just
this always kind of bugs me it's a
little peeve it's a comedy peeve
but sometimes like a person at the show
will just come in the green room and i'm
just like
it's oh yeah i'm a dude but if that's a
female comic you should maybe uh
police that a little bit yeah yeah but i
had a guy who was just drunk and he came
in the green room not
wise guys he comes in hammered and uh
and i'm kind of like
can i help you and he goes uh he goes
kind of a picture
no and he's just this big drunk and i'm
like dude you can't just come back here
i'll take a picture of you can't do that
right and uh and then the
owner of the club comes back and goes
heard you almost got raped
i was like uh yeah and
and and they say uh what it was a joke i
was like you're running a business
right what are you doing yeah and how do
you know i didn't
get raped but yeah no that is just a
curtain you know that's that's the whole
thing
or sometimes it's the room sometimes
it's kind of cool it is cool when you
walk through the kitchen to get to the
ground
you feel like you're in good fellas i
love that yeah i thought you were in
construction
yeah i love the kitchen walk but yeah
great club and those crowds just love
comedy
denver and salt lake something about
those two cities they just
eat up comedy maybe that's it maybe the
mountains i don't know
it's beautiful yeah it's fun bringing
some on the road who's never been there
so because devito and i the second we
land in salt lake he just looks the
mountains and goes oh my
god i was like oh man you need that
energy sometimes because we get so jaded
like oh another weekend and then he's
like dude this is like gorgeous i'm like
yeah it really is i know and then you're
just like bam five hours and we're in
the
whole another universe like this
mountain is just staring at you the
people are different
there's no diversity uh high elevation
you know it's bad with diversity when i
see a black guy and i get excited i'm
like thank god i got some color in my
show this is crazy
no but then when you take a photo with
him and chase him he's like what the
[ __ ] but yeah yeah i know it's
it's crazy i think uh my i i worked
there
years ago and my host was black and he's
like dude i love coming here i'm like
really he's like yeah i clean up
i'm like exotic you know it's like going
to sweden
yeah that's interesting yeah my host was
a killer great great jokes really funny
stuff it's so nice when uh
you know the club just throws someone up
who's really strong he
he was there last time i was there too
that's really one of the best clubs in
the country
one of the best we we did a thing we
were talking about our best clubs and
like i i don't know how we left that one
off
yeah that's the problem with doing those
things you always leave clubs off but
why is guys in salt lake
incredible and then when you take a guy
there like uh devito
your opener there he's like oh this is
what comedy can be
you know because we we get our ass
kicked in the city we're at a bar show
in brooklyn or or
some [ __ ] up funny bone so when you
get to these great clubs it's like
it's a really special thing it's the
best man yeah it was
it was a good weekend it was just killer
shows
uh yeah i'm just happy to be on the road
again man it's nice to be back it's good
to have an outlet
you're like oh this is my purpose in
life working on an hour
going out killing in front of strangers
the time goes quickly though you like
people are like why don't you do this on
the road i'm like well i do a pod with
you i do it bro
you know so you're doing those like
bonus steps on the road yeah doing like
then you kind of need to sleep one day
that's true yeah then you get drunk one
night so that that ruins a day
yeah yeah uh david spade i heard
hires a guy now just to stand outside
the green room
really just because so many people run
back there well he almost got killed by
an assistant
oh that's remembering his assistant
tried to like david spade could have
died
wow was what happened he had a crazy
assistant who just
[ __ ] broke into his place and tried
to kill him
holy i think he fired him because the
guy was a bad assistant and then it
turned out he was an even worse human i
guess i don't know
crazy spade is some of those classic
jokes where i love uh
i just love how sarcastic he is he's one
of my favorites when you when you're on
a flight and
and the pilot they always say they
always tell you their name
like someone on the plane is like oh
he's good i like his work
that's so his uh he's dry he's so dry
yeah now he's great nate bergatzi's
favorite comic
he's a great comic great guy people
don't know how funny spade is who are
like really young i mean
no but they don't like i've had people
be like uh oh i didn't know he was this
funny
yeah oh because we grew up in the 90s
were like tommy boy
and you know yeah just shoot me yeah snl
new york minute remember that was that
was it was he had a thing like
a uh like a desk piece yeah spade
america
that was it where he'd be like casino
came out it was great when it was called
good fellas he would do jokes like that
he was like he was like the first kind
of [ __ ] comic of our generation
yeah then i remember terry hatcher came
on and put on a blonde short wig and she
was like
uh black sheep is out i liked it better
when it was called tommy boy
oh wow oh that's great and he just went
oh yeah
yeah he was good it's so crazy to lose
your kind of like comedy soul mate he
lost farley you know and uh
he died holy [ __ ]
yeah that is sad i mean it's so weird to
you like that you're like we're gonna do
this for 40 years he probably thought i
know
i know but uh he was one of those guys
like you hear those stories
the [ __ ] i've heard about him they said
one time
uh he jerked off on in spades notebook
and closed it
and spade's like ah gee because he knew
what it was
he was like such a wild guy that he was
like ah he jerked off of my book again
damn yeah like farley was wild he jerked
off in his notebook he did [ __ ] like
that all the time like you turn around
and he's just balls around he's like ah
you know stuff like that where
he would you know be cancelled in the
second but i always said sno used to
have balls but wow
they really uh no that's farley was the
funniest man
oh yeah oh yeah i mean he had it all he
was like a cartoon character falling
through tables
fat guy and little coat the best yeah
who's your who's your like top snl
person ever i usually say phil hartman
to say that's mine
oh really oh caveman lawyer come on so
good so good he was on
the harvey's up there eddie murphy
obviously yeah yeah
well i think will ferrell's up there
yeah yeah it's tough
there's so many good ones uh let's see
hmm i mean i love norm too
yeah incredible norm doing no he's
underrated you know he's underrated we
can update his kevin nealon man
oh yeah he was great he's great yeah
he's got a solid act too
yeah i had to follow him in la once i
was like man those jokes are great
he brought me up once to the comedy
store and he did not
it was hilarious where it's like he just
didn't know who to bring up
and i'd work with him like pretty
recently but it's like he's like wait
who am i bringing up and the waitress
goes
sam morale and he goes who and i got a
huge laugh
that's funny here we go yeah you already
feel a little out of water at la
and then you hear that [ __ ] and you're
like oh god then he's on my face he was
like oh
he was like yeah haven't you worked with
him i opened for a caroline's
back in the day he's such a nice guy and
really funny and was like gave me tags
wow he was like watch my act i think
they wanted someone clean for him and i
wasn't quite
what he wanted yeah but he was still
really cool and uh
yeah great guy it's funny because uh
carol we used to hang out at caroline's
for years when's the last time you step
foot in there i've been in there and i
don't know how long two years three
years
airlines on broadway 49th and yeah
there's an event before cover but yeah
we
i mean i watched you i would go watch
you open for a guy that's how you know
little i had going on but i remember
watching you open for jim jeffries
and you did the the no bit and he was
like
that's a great joke and i remember i got
to hear
jim jeffries say my friend had a great
joke and he was like that's great that's
great he's like hitting me he's you know
he's like already in a blackout
he's not even on yet but uh that was
like it meant a lot that he was so cool
i mean i was that was like
10 years ago probably more yeah so it
meant a lot to he was so cool
he was so cool he took us out after miyu
che
yes that was great and he was like uh
you know he's just a fun guy he almost
came to my family thanksgiving which in
retrospect
thank god he was too hungover i just
pictured him going to my mother he's
like a very proper woman
got an anecdote for you people i was
[ __ ] a toy hooker in the ass the
other night
my mom was like oh dear oh yeah that
would have been like arthur
the movie having him at your house he
would have been a good arthur
he'd be a great arthur they did they re
[ __ ] they redo movies so they redid
arthur
brand i like russell brand but it's like
this was their
they always need like this is our spin
john giglid
is going to be a woman helen right right
i didn't see the movie but i could just
tell they made it too
bright and colorful yes it too disnified
it was like it looked like whimsical you
want that movie to have like a sadness
to it
he was a sad drunk sad drunk and you
loved him for it uh it's the same with
charlie and the chocolate factory they
remade that it was too whimsical it had
johnny depp he was all quirky it's like
no that movie's got to have some [ __ ]
like darkness to it that movie's dark
you can't do that anymore this is
interesting i mean charles grodin just
died he was a [ __ ] brilliant comic
actor
name one big comic actor who's dry
oh you can't have subtlety in a big
company anymore
have subtleties watch the heartbreak kid
with with uh
charles grodin watch me run with charles
gruden amazing blind's in
in the heartbreak kid where he's you
know trying he's talking to the girl's
father
yeah and he goes i didn't serve in the
war in vietnam like you did but i
i served at the war here fighting
against injustice you know
just like he's [ __ ] up just he's just
a horrible piece that's why that
remake didn't work because yeah because
he was like ben stiller was like kind of
cool in it like right
right charles gruden's a [ __ ] loser
in that movie of course
the loser is always funnier the only
thing a little more take more
take more the closest thing to the dry
comic actor now is probably vince vaughn
and it's still not that dry but he's
probably the closest you know
he's like a big actor yeah he's an old
school he's making like the quips
off to the side side of the mouth kind
of [ __ ] in that movie
yeah he's he's probably the only one
because we had bill murray for a while
but then he kind of
murray was that he was the kind of he
was the guy big
grodin so he's another line i mean so
many great lines but
midnight runs one of those perfect
movies where uh
it's it's got everything it's yeah it's
a buddy comedy movie we i mean we were
sucking off the nice guys on the patreon
oh yeah
it's a buddy comedy two guys who hate
each other
a bunch of colorful characters you got
joe pontilliano dennis farina yafet kodo
just
also passed away but then dude it's so
many like the line where he meets
de niro's family and he goes he's a
criminal and and the kid goes
he doesn't look like a criminal i'm a
white collar criminal
that's a [ __ ] great lie ah that's
great i i grodin's the best
yeah yeah you don't get to drive nuance
is out
but i think it's it's living and
prospering on the internet
because like real comedy fans are like
all right i'll go to youtube or whatever
and you got to find your guy now
yeah but you're right but dry is harder
to because it's all about going viral
and
and it's a more like three-dimensional
trait in a character yeah as opposed to
like the quick silly guy
but uh yeah we're going for numbers now
we're going for a mainstream
yeah and that's kind of hurting things
we saw him on the street once i was with
my buddy scott rogowsky and marion
grodin
charles grodin's daughter is a stand-up
and
and she's really cool we run into her on
the street and i just go hey marion i
thought i'd look over i'm like that's
[ __ ] charles grodin i just
look at scott who's like the biggest
grodden fan jaw dropped
wow that's wild you're just like man
that guy was like
so dry yeah he was the driest like my ex
but uh yeah yeah yeah he'll be missed we
had a with a mooney and a groaning in a
week
mooney is a is another like just badass
comic
another caroline's did you ever watch
him do like a long set oh yeah many
times i've watched hours of moonie never
got to open i uh never got
picked that was a tough gig yeah it's
okay to show up like 90 minutes later so
sometimes you just got some like regular
comics just being like i guess i gotta
do 90.
yes you had to stretch baby and that
crowd was not
into you they were in they were waiting
for him but he would walk his own crowd
sometimes
really he didn't give a [ __ ] he did not
give a [ __ ] but in a in a way that was
authentic i mean like
you said chappelle said something about
him right about yeah he said i saw
chappelle pop in at the stand it was
pretty great
chris rock jon stewart and chappelle did
a whole
mooney tribute which was really nice but
he had the best
line about mooney said he could have
been huge
he was brilliant enough he was a great
enough writer i mean he wrote for pryor
for christ's sake every special you see
his name in the credits
exactly blazing saddles all that [ __ ] so
he could have been huge but he
sacrificed to having a big career
just to keep it real yeah which is like
wow
when you hear that you're like that's so
true he did he kept it so real
he just wanted to say what he wanted to
say and it wasn't for everybody
and it's not gonna work and get you
mainstream success but
if he chose his path white man can't
jump who cares he owns the team
[Laughter]
he has so many funny lies i mean he
really talks [ __ ] to white people in a
hilarious way
i remember i met him once i did a
friar's club roast i was 21
i bombed harder than i've ever bombed in
my life it was a humiliating night
paul mooney i've never seen a guy who i
thought was like i looked up to the guy
obviously
i knew who he was and he was just
phoning this set in like i've
always seen and it was hilarious to
watch him just kind of get nothing and
be like i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah he did not give a [ __ ] and he bro
he brought me on to just like nothing he
goes his next comic
he just like read something i think i
had like a blurb he's like you've seen
it he's a fan of kennison
he's a fan of bill hicks he's a fan of
uh richard pryor i knew all of them
all dead give it up for sam morrell that
was my intro
to just you just cut to me and just like
and i just bombed for like and then you
know
and then rich voss went on after me and
his first joke bombed he goes you better
laugh or i'm bringing sam back up
it killed that's a great line killed
manny sacrificed your ass for a for a
laugh
i was just i was [ __ ] hilarious but
wow what what bob what was so bad that
about your set
was it i think it's weird i don't i just
didn't have any
chops i just i wasn't they could smell
the fear maybe totally
i did an audition to get that they did
like open calls at
gotham and it was like during the day
and
i remember seeing like richard belzer
was in there like petting a dog a little
dog
this is so weird uh eddie brill was like
one of the judges i think was like a
couple other
comics judging it and i went up and i
killed i had like just jokes about
they were like just give any i think it
was just like a random celebrity just
roast them and i did i think it was like
simon cowell
and i was killing i was like i was so
nervous but it went well i was like
they're like you're in you got it
wow and then i just wasn't good i just
watched the next
i was it was [ __ ] it was like i
didn't have
i was too new i was 21 i just didn't
have wow that's pretty wild you had that
experience was it the friars club yeah
it was humiliating wow
oh it was the roast of omarosa oh my god
what year was this 08 or something oh
seven
wow holy [ __ ] that's wild horrible
man what a time capsule omarosa
she was very very attractive sleepy hot
lady yeah or sneaky hot lady
before she was part of trump's cabinet
yeah she's a pretty
hell of a cheekbone on but uh yeah wow
that's a that's a crazy night and that's
one of those nights you probably had a
suit on
i did so you're 21 and posted a picture
with mooney on instagram
i saw oh that's the pick yeah is that
night yeah oh i'm sure he hated taking
that picture yeah you could just see in
his eyes this guy ain't going anywhere
well you beat him technically i won't go
that far i mean he he
he's just such a cool character i mean a
lot of younger people know him from
chappelle show and like
obviously that's like what that helped a
lot of us
yeah how cool he was i mean it's so
[ __ ] funny in those so funny so funny
he probably wrote a bunch of that [ __ ] i
mean he's just
he was just a great comedy mind and he
has a uh
episode of the green room yeah it's
great and him and bobby slayton
who are you know both titans of that era
going back
and forth and bobby slayton says the
n-word and paul mooney just rolls his
eyes it's [ __ ] great
i'm yeah it's like paul mooney's like
i've heard this [ __ ] before exactly
you're not gonna you're not gonna get me
the green room was a great show
great show it's on youtube check that
out that's a wreck
wreck paul provenza also a great dude
yeah good guy
who who loves comedy more than prevents
yeah he's brought a book
satiristas and uh yeah the green room is
killer he had a show
in the 90s where he just like
interviewed comics nobody watched it i'm
sure but it was like bill hicks is on
i saw that yeah louie's on one louie's
got a white sox with dress shoes he
looks like an idiot
it's fun to watch david tell all these
guys oh my god
but yeah now i feel like we're going too
deep we're going through let's go give
me a peeve give me a pee steve
i have so many i mean basketball one
tonight i had was uh
uh oh here's one the guy who just like
stands up
in the [ __ ] in the aisle and it's
like a no rush to get a seat i'll just
stand here for a second to watch
yeah you're obstructing the view you
piece of [ __ ] i nearly got my ass kicked
because
this guy wouldn't move he just wouldn't
move and i go
i and some people go and sit down sit
down and finally i got to close the shot
and go
shut the [ __ ] down and he turns around
and he gives me the dirtiest look he
goes calm down
whoa and i was just like and i just gave
him a look back and we kind of stared at
each other and i was like i think that
dude could take me
but man the energy of this game was it
was bananas i'm like i i paid a lot of
money for these seats i don't want to
[ __ ] you know
yeah i don't want to miss out damn what
was it long island out there you think
coming in a little long island a little
a little bit every that's the beauty of
madison square garden you get you get
literally every borough that's true you
get the suburbs you get everything
jersey
long island maybe some west chester yeah
the real i mean i feel like a lot of
jersey people are knicks fans because
[ __ ] the nets dude yeah yeah and the
nets are brooklyn
i don't know nick's i'm a knicks fan
forever so that's a
i got another peeve all right these
people
on on airplanes so two peeves one
they don't respect the zone oh zone is
big i
live for those zones that's my whole
life is built around the zone
it's kind of like it's so weird when
they're like all right we're boarding
this people now and literally
every person just stands there yes i go
literally when i'm cold i don't
right you're not you're slowing down the
whole process because now the people
that are boarding before you have to
like
weave through you exactly so i hate that
[ __ ] that's a peeve
uh-huh you hate the the the weaving or
you hate the gathering
i hate the fact that you have to weave
because of the gathering i enjoy the
weave though it feels kind of cool
excuse me get out of my way i'm
important you're not
all right i got the delta comfort but
comfort man
oh that's that's all i don't need first
class i do oh really well
the gams i mean look i had comfort today
i prefer for i mean it's just like
it depends on it depends how long a
flight we're talking yeah yeah if you
got that new york to la
or seattle or portland it's tough not to
but yeah i
i don't know yeah well the exit row is
kind of a poor man's first class
you gotta risk your life i'm fine with
that it's kind of like going to war
yeah but then you come back and you're
like all right you get some respect here
yeah exactly i i who has ever has anyone
ever gone like
hey do you feel comfortable in a case of
emergency is anyone going
nah i don't think i can handle it i
think people have oh really i think
sure i'm in the history there must have
been someone who's like yeah i'm a
coward i don't want to do it
all you got to do is pull the latch up i
don't know i don't know it doesn't seem
that crazy also i feel like
if it gets that bad you could just be a
coward and be like i don't give a [ __ ]
that's true you could jump
out get some other guy yeah that's true
i would love to save the day on a plane
though that would be the highlight of my
life in what way like sully are we
talking like mark wahlberg hypothetical
911.
sully is never going to happen because i
can't fly a plane but
i'm talking tackle a guy who's like
belligerent or
whatever in the aisle because i feel
like people would have your back you
wouldn't even be
fighting with a guy for that long you
know people would help you but if you
make the first move
i would i would love to be that guy then
you get like you get dealt the lounge
for the rest of your life
donald sterling guy in the plane leave
him alone yeah
yeah yeah i would love to save the save
the day on a plane
that would be badass that would really
be something and what a credit
i mean [ __ ] a tonight show you know him
from uh
the united viral clip you know him
saying get off my plane to some russian
scumbag
one of the greatest bad movies of all
time yeah
air force one is so cheesy i love that
movie
it's so good i had the vhs oh dude oh
yeah
i remember when the mtv awards used to
be like a bigger thing and they'd be
like
the in the line of the year get off my
plan i was like yeah
yeah that was pre-911 right yeah yeah
gary oldman that was that's back when
russian terrorists were the biggest yes
yes exactly yeah those were the days
it was fine to hate russia everybody can
get on board with that it's such a
hilarious propaganda vehicle where it's
like
uh [ __ ] harry can you pull up any of uh
air force one it's so that last scene is
so funny yeah just a scene where he
he's fighting with uh gary oldman and
it's like of course the president
like not only he saves the day yeah such
hilarious
horseshit propaganda it's some real
patriotism uh
americana [ __ ] you know like oh our
president is not only like handsome and
nice but he can kick
ass harrison ford does rock though oh
i love him i love his dumb earring i
love that he can fly a plane
i'm a fan did you see the viral clip of
him where the guy showed him the magic
trick
no some guy did magic in his home and he
was like
what the [ __ ] did you do it was like in
the most harrison ford way possible
he was just freaking out at a magic
trick i have seen the clip of him at
comic con where it he's like uh
what grow up he's like yelling at these
kids like get out of your mom's basement
go
go get a hobby you losers and they're
all like
no solo han we love you yeah i'd love to
jump on board but i'm wearing a jersey
of a man who's younger than me
my body right now well i mean we're
getting old you know
somebody had a good point they said you
know you're getting old when police are
younger than you and you're like oh
that's true you know used to copies
coming to the window and you go oh yeah
sorry sir and now
i'm like hey what who what is you 18.
yeah like go home
yeah what are you doing out clap is uh
i have a lot of new cop jokes i might
that might be my bed for this week i
might run one that's not really
it's not really there yet but i might
run that by you all right yeah play it
on me
let me throw let's do the ad we gotta
get an ad here for you
folks all right all right all right
here we go did you email it their hair
oh you texted it okay even better
beautiful i love
text hate emails love it we might be
drunk is brought to you by
upstart do you dread looking at your
credit card statement every month
we don't blame you but upstart can help
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
online you know it's hard to get out of
debt you might
you know spread yourself too thin maybe
you got a hooker addiction a porn
addiction
you like to pay for it you're not like
one of those cheapos who gets it all
free online maybe you've got a drug
problem
who the [ __ ] knows why you're in debt
college is expensive
uh but uh but
upstart is here to help unlike other
lenders upstart looks
at more than just your credit score like
your income your employment history
that means they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners just a five minute
online rate check
you can get fast approved the same day
and can receive funds as fast as one
business day
mark tell them how to do it you gotta do
it folks find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payments today when you go
to upstart.com
drunk that's us that's upstart.com
drunk don't forget to use url to let
them know
i sent you and uh you got to throw in a
disclaimer folks you know how the
business goes
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
and now go to upstart.com
drunk and get on it today i think we're
both getting slash drunk
i know right i'm slash slurring give me
give me a peeve
all right oh you got it i got some i got
some interesting stuff this week okay
peeve this happened to me all weekend
and i think it's uh i don't know
maybe we're comics we're out every night
we're we're riffing and rapping we're
chopping it up with all kinds of
different folk
the guy who you kind of know who you
bump into
and he keeps asking how are you because
he has nothing else to say
you know you go i go hey man good to see
you man what's it been like two years
he's like
i know how are you i'm good i'm good i'm
good things are going great i'm back on
the road
uh what's going on with you oh you know
uh being the lady we're we're living up
here
how about how are you i'm good i'm good
and after the third how are you
i i'm out of stuff i'm talking
everything i'm tired of how i am
yes yeah i'm i'm tapped out stop asking
me how are you let's actually have a
conversation
i told you how i am twice i made up two
of them because i had to fill
fill dead air it's it's tough because
it's almost like
we've all done those morning radio show
spots on the road where they have like
nothing and we just have to like take it
over
that's what they're asking me to do but
i get [ __ ] some of these gigs i'm
tired man
right you're so right but like i just
want to have a conversation a back and
forth and
then i feel guilty if i take over the
whole thing i don't want to just make
this about me so i want to include and
have a an equal opportunity here but
how are you how are you but they're
asking you to dominate the conversation
and they're making you feel guilty it's
like a double [ __ ] you kind
yes exactly i felt guilty and then i'm
like
i'm good i'm good uh what's up with you
or and now we're just in this weird
stalemate or whatever
is that it stalemate is that a thing i
don't know
it's a stalemate still made is like
isn't it a chess term
probably yeah yeah it's a chess term
when i think neither you can win i guess
it works
okay i just use it i think blindly oh
man speaking of chess
the queen's gambit uh girl was at the
game tonight what she is hot
oh yeah yeah i got a nugget for her she
lives in my building
really true story damn
pretty wild her husband is or a
boyfriend or whatever he's uh
is a beautiful man really he's like six
six like
ripped you know hot guy with the the
v-neck and a leather jacket
you could pull off a leather jacket yeah
i'm working on it
you've done it for episodes here that's
our highest uh viewed episode by the way
is it
do you think it's good i think it's the
lj i like it man
all right that that's one people hey
just have a conversation enough with the
how are you
it's it's tough they're asking you to do
the heavy lifting
all right so then i'm in hartford so you
got a drink
it's the only way to get through it and
uh i got this one and i hope we haven't
covered this before but i got this one
from everybody i'm trying i've been so
hungover lately i guess i'm getting old
or whatever it is
but i've been trying to kill the
hangovers and and fight back
so i have i heard if you have a glass of
water between every drink
you're gonna be fine which is not true
but i tried it
but i had the guy going water really
water i'm like i'm gonna keep drinking
i'm just trying to stay hydrated for the
hangover tomorrow
this isn't some kind of attack on booze
or
or alcoholism i just need the water it's
the most natural resource i can't have a
glass
i know why are you making this why are
you making us dude i do the same thing
because
i'm gonna say i want to be able to
function then yes exactly i don't want
to lose a day bartender you mean
what's that it's the bartender no it was
a guy i was hanging out with so he's
like really water you drinking water
whoa what a what a weirdo what a [ __ ]
i'm like
i'm still boozing i've had more drinks
than you probably
but i just would like to have a life
tomorrow
yeah i don't i i don't like people
getting involved
in your routine how about that you do
your thing and i'll do mine
as long as i we talked about this on the
patreon people who get mad when you
leave too
when they're just like come on you're
like i've been here all [ __ ] night i
know
how about if i leave when i want to
leave it makes me like be like well i'm
not going to come hang out with you next
time i leave when i want to leave
that's why irish exits are so underrated
oh i love an irish
no and also guess what when this guy's
that drunk they're not going to remember
anyway you're just you're just saving
yourself an ugly confrontation
right right exactly so that's why people
do it
yeah it's just easier and you're not
going to remember anyway you're going to
wake up tomorrow you're not going to go
whatever what happened to that guy
you're just going to
it's going to go on with your [ __ ] that
is that why the it's called the irish
exodus because the irish are probably
the meanest
when you leave oh you're pro cause
they're a bunch of drunks because
they're drunks they probably call you a
[ __ ] if you leave and then
that's probably how i would invent it i
don't want to piss them off yeah i love
it i mean
i think it's it's weirdly uh considerate
in a way like
look you guys keep having fun i'm a
downer i'll just
be on my mosey way here also how about
like
sometimes you're out of [ __ ] to give and
you're like yeah
i need some me time like we talk about
it we're both comics we're out all the
time
yeah i think we're both kind of
introverted at the end of the day of
course
of course you need those recharge time
it's like you know what's good for you
don't guilt someone to hanging out
that's not your [ __ ] friend
i know and not to be a [ __ ] but how
great is this party if you if you
desperately need me there
oh dude how about those texts come to
this party it's great i feel like if it
were you wouldn't be pushing me so yeah
yeah yeah if you're if you're eating out
l mcpherson you're not texting me
you know what i mean i like your hot
chick references like 50 something now
i couldn't think of it if you're banging
christy brinkley i feel like
uh you got sidney crawford on the blower
hang on to that one oh
man
that's a great one i'll tell you if
carmen elektra is on the horn
don't hang up on her uh
if you like a little liasman blithe
action
i think we've we've done all of baywatch
did we just did we just
uh talk about every woman we jacked off
yeah pretty much
on our first like year rubbing out this
is my first year
yeah yeah if you know xena the warrior
princess
and you're fingering her all right what
if this took a turn i was like if you
know
hercules oh kevin sorbo wait a minute
that dude's gone off the deep end oh
he was like one of the dudes cheering on
the capital trashing
was he yeah he was like tweeting he was
like they're finally coming
i'm like ooh this is a bad luck yeah him
james woods is another one who went
went wild went nuts great actor though
great
actor phenomenal actor great role he was
on a columbo back in the day too oh
murderer sorry to give that one away but
he was the bad guy but you should have
known it was james woods
yeah the second you see him you're like
you you did it
yeah yeah it's so true he was great as a
uh lester lester diamond and casino oh
great god he was great the weasel
yes yes there's always that guy who's
like talking to your girl and you're
like who is that guy she's like
he's harmless you're like i don't think
he is harmless i don't like that guy
lester weasel or lester diamond sorry uh
all right all right you gotta
here's my wreck you're wrecking the
green room great wreck
i'm wrecking two things even though i
probably should save one maybe i'll save
one for next step
i gotta say i was shocked and surprised
hbo has got a new show about stand-up
it's kind of loosely based on joan
rivers
oh yeah it looks great hacks it's killer
hacks is great
i watched it with the lady we were both
like this is a good show this is good
writing
i mean they nail comedy how many
millions of comedy shows have come out
where you're like that's not what it's
like
that's so ridiculous that would never
happen you know they get heckled and the
woman's on her first
first ever show and she's killing the
guy you know you're like no
she would crumble but this is like
really realistic
timely very poignant interesting
well-written hbo max it looks great
i remember i remember taylor redford i
was like
i was just like doing the sides with her
for audition i remember being like i
like this dialogue a lot the dialogue's
good and the premise is so
perfect i never like the dialogue on
these auditions oh they're the worst
but yeah it's it is a good premise like
joan rivers and like a protege kind of
yeah and the protege is like an entitled
hipster kind of
gen z she wrote a blog everybody liked
the blog so then she got hired on the
show
and now she's entitled she's like i
shouldn't have to i i was on that show
why do i have to keep trying and work
hard and then joan rivers like
you got to work you got lucky you you i
had to like do the clubs for years you
just wrote on a blog
so then the girl gets canceled for a
tweet about a gay
senator and then uh so this joan lady
hires her
and uh she's miserable it's it's really
interesting
it's it's a it's a good show it looks
[ __ ] great man
yeah i i it was so i was so impressed
with it that i
emailed the writer the head writer who
this
woman jen statsky oh yeah i follow her
on twitter she's good
her tweets are funny too she's a
basketball head oh really yeah yeah so i
messaged her i dm'd i was like just want
to say i've seen a million shows by
stand up this one's actually
realistic it makes sense and really
funny the writing's great and she wrote
back thanks i appreciate that she's been
around
she's written on a lot of stuff yeah i
see that i see her name pop up a lot
she's a pro i mean the show is really
well done
damn i had a movie and i can't remember
my wreck now
i'm [ __ ] an idiot ah
yeah well this doesn't help yeah this is
not helping yeah this can't be good
for us i had like three points when you
were talking and i lost them all because
i like got into what you were saying so
it happens
it's funny every time i talk to people
like that's a great idea for a podcast
you guys just get drunk and i'm like hey
you should listen to an episode
we lose a lot it's for the first 30
minutes they're like oh these guys are
uh
you know on to something that's like the
opposite of marin
you got to stick around for the
beginning right right right exactly
yeah this pod's like a marriage in the
beginning it's great and it just
crumbles
[ __ ] man i'm trying to think uh all
right i'll save the other wreck
i should ask i don't want to i don't
want to blow it out that's what the
movie was because i know
oh you got a you saw a great movie i've
seen it but
we also you also wrecked heartbreak kid
you know what maybe i
gotta get i got a good yeah but those
are i've wrecked those a million times i
got a good wreck for you all right all
right
peeky blinders i think you wrecked this
before
no no no i i think i i mentioned i liked
it on the page oh okay okay no i think i
wrecked watchman last week didn't i last
week yeah
i thought maybe this was an older rep
but no no no i just started watching it
i like it a lot if i wreck this for the
second time i apologize
i like it because it's like uh they're
always getting drunk
they're always smoking the main
character is [ __ ] up from the war it's
kind of got a draper thing going on
yes the dialogue is very noir there's a
line where he's trying to get one of the
women to
this woman is bartender he's trying to
get her and she's an undercover cop he's
trying to get her to
hook up with this gangster that he wants
to be in business with and she goes i'm
not a [ __ ] and he said we all are we
just sell different parts of ourselves
i love dialogue like that killian
murphy's a great actor
the acting's great it gets a little doer
at times the color is so gloomy but i'm
i'm in i'm i'm into it
i watched the first season and uh
it's really well done like the set
pieces and all that it really like
it's cool like cinema yeah i'm into it
style so i like it but
it it was one of those i never got back
in you know that second season is tough
now
my buddy dory pushed me so hard to watch
it that i finally was like
it's one of those shows that you need to
be put
most netflix originals suck that's true
but
we're also we're all we're such pampered
[ __ ] like when you said succession
i looked i was like ah this looks a
little slow and maybe boring and then i
was
i'm obsessed with succession i cannot
wait for the third season
i'm so pumped special on tv it might be
the best show on tv so if you just push
through i mean the wire
how many times i try the wire four times
and then i eventually got going
so yeah sometimes it takes a little bit
of a
a push yeah but yeah yeah i like it
he's a hot guy who murphy yeah he's like
weird is like those eyes
yeah is this dude handsome or just scary
exactly
i've talked to girls like oh he's so hot
he's so sexy but
who's your number one if you went gay
who'd you hook up with for who have you
thought about
prime clooney looks pretty good prime
clue
oh great movie it's
soderbergh sodaboo and it's cool i saw
clooney an interview say like he needed
a hit
because he wasn't viable as a movie star
and it wasn't even a hit but it was so
well
liked by critics that it kind of saved
him soderbergh needed a hit
wow yeah j-lo is hot as hell in it so
you got dennis farina cheatle
cheadle's great in it yeah steve zahn
yeah
he's underrated as a community actor uh
isaiah washington one of the first
actors to get cancelled in the last 20
years what did he do he said he called a
gay guy that slur
yeah wow he got cancelled which you're
like damn is there no path to redemption
though
but then so then he uh which is like a
blogger word i'm sorry even said that is
there no path to redemption
truth to power that's another big one i
hear a lot
so then uh yeah the whole cast is
incredible
ving rhames oh yeah he's never not good
love
the wing love the ving reigns great
movie so yeah we watched that and i was
like man i haven't seen this in a while
but the dialogue is just
killer and the first scene clooney's
robbing the bank and he's just he plays
an ass oh albert brooks albert brooks
yeah he just plays an [ __ ] it's fun
to see clooney play kind of like a
a bad dude yeah yeah no he's it's it's
so stylized too and it looks great it's
kind of a throwback to like a weird
70s just kind of heisty
uh sexy cool movie clooney young
clooney's pretty hard
yeah yeah yeah who else i definitely
like uh
who has really grabbed you though who
are you like man that guy is cool as
[ __ ] i'd love to
blow him you know who's a really
handsome man
is uh michael b jordan oh yeah
he is a good really good looking guy so
ripped he's so ripped he's like because
you got to go like action star because
he's used to take care of themselves i
know
michael b jordan you're like are you
playing like superheroes you're playing
[ __ ] creed oh here we go he also
is uh gq does this thing on youtube
where they go like
give us your daily routine like what do
you do every morning
and then throughout the day and he did
one and he was so cool and chill
and regular that it made me like them
all that'd be yeah because i was ready
to not like him if you're going to be
like i wake up at 5 00 a.m
yeah i have an avocado smoothie like ugh
that wasn't that's the rock
those guys are in there brady yes
exactly but
then you look at tom brady shirtless and
you're like you look like [ __ ]
he's kind of skinny fat yeah but then
he's just like an incredible so maybe
it's like it's not about how you look
right well a lot of mma guys are like
this guy looks like
doughy and chubby but then they can kick
ass so hey who knows oh dude
cormier yeah you should not be able to
fight that guy's amazing
he's incredible one of the best of all
time who you gotta give me some of you
guys
well i would i got a weird thing for
oscar is it oscar isaac
oh yeah yeah he's something about that
guy is is uh he's a handsome guy
worthy swarthy i like i think if i was a
lady i would go swarthy
yeah short though you're cool with that
yeah sure well i i'm okay with it
because i keep an open mind i'm not as
shallow as most ladies but uh
i you know i'm i'm 5 10. so i got to
give it up to the
the under six guys but uh he's such a
good actor i love the choices he picked
he's got great roles
you know ex machina davis
oh so he's both two of the most just
awesome movies the last 20 years i think
yeah and then but then if we're going
cool guy
skill level tom hardy wow
pretty high i feel like he would hurt
you yeah i could see that
he's like a heartbreaker but i feel like
he also might [ __ ] you too hard yeah
don't you think yeah i can see that but
he's just so
good and like in interviews he's he's
quick and funny
you got to have quick do you ever see
the movie lock
is that the one where he's that's the
one he's just
he's just in the car for the entire time
i don't think i have the entire movie is
him just in a car
in a car and it it's like he does phone
calls and that's the whole movie what
it it works come on it's [ __ ] great
is he driving or is he in the back seat
he's driving but it's like
he'll get a phone call and you'll be
like stakes just
all of a sudden happen and you're just
like wow that's pretty crazy that i just
felt that much from just a phone call
but it's it's pretty crazy
does he get out of the car not really no
what
it's i'm telling you it's it's i respect
movies where you're like this
is the weirdest this must have been the
weirdest pitch yeah yeah right
but you got tom hardy so they're like
well we'll take it but i've seen phone
booth
and that sucked they look like [ __ ] it's
just a guy in a phone booth
and they're like if you leave this phone
booth we're gonna blow it up or whatever
the hell it is so it's an interesting
premise but you're like first of all i
haven't seen a phone booth since 1988
and secondly i don't know i'm not that
invested
yeah how would you stand on uh bang
ability on
like a colin farrell i think he's a
handsome guy and you know in bruges
is great he's got the accent he probably
is a fun drunk
so i think he's a bangable bangable but
i feel like
it's a low hit rate i feel like he only
would get hard like
every like five or six lays interesting
and then some of them would be like
crazy heart hard where like you're hard
but it's only for like part of the time
yeah yeah that's i can see that it's
kind of like his career
yeah you know but he he also has the
whiskey dick then we've all heard the
irish curse
ooh true so you know if i'm going to go
gay one night i'd like to have at least
a decent hog
who else are you thinking uh let's see
uh
christian bale not too shabby yeah but
he seems like he's got anger problems
yeah like he would he would like be in a
character and take it out on you
right right that's why i'm not [ __ ]
daniel day
that would be a nightmare he's like two
in the role he's like method
he's like [ __ ] lincoln too again this
sucks
i thought you died at the end of this
[ __ ] what the hell i know where's booth
didn't he quit acting yeah and now he's
back in acting
oh is he i don't think he's back oh i
thought he was i thought he came back
well he did phantom threat i think that
was it
oh god that was a good movie was it good
i liked it's very slow
yeah yeah but you're like this dude's
great i mean you could do worse [ __ ]
than watch that dude
okay no i agree i agree he's a he's a
beast but
i feel like every movie this year in the
oscars was slow
i i couldn't i they all none of them
looked like movies i wanted to watch
same you know what the problem is those
are movies that i can watch if i went to
the theater and made a night of it but
they're not movies i can watch at home
it's like watching a foreign film if i
see one playing in the theater
i'm in right but at home i'm like ah
it's hard to just stay locked in
i completely agree you got the phone
there you got the laptop there you got
everything else there it's hard to it's
got to be like if it's like
a classic i'll i'll go all in on it
does that worry you and i know we got to
start wrapping this up but does that
worry you about your attention span
because i grew up watching movies i grew
up watching
tv all day and it was just tv or i'd
read a book or i'd go skate or whatever
it was
but i would just i would be locked into
a movie and i
i loved every minute of it i didn't want
it to end and now i'm like
oh it's a good movie oh [ __ ] i gotta
tweet something depends if i'm alone
depends
i try to put the phone down if i'm gonna
watch a movie that
i mean but also part of it's like a lot
of movies are [ __ ] now
all the movies a lot of movies we grew
up on we were all in on [ __ ] movies like
think about how many bad movies you're
like i'm just gonna watch this whole
thing and have no distractions and it's
like
that movie didn't earn my attention
interesting i i'm not saying it's
healthy but also like
if it's a good movie i'm gonna give it a
shot like i don't know like
if i'm watching even like a good show
i'm gonna try a lot of shows get greedy
though now or like
it'll be like an hour-long show and like
three scenes are good
right that's true there's a lot of that
so it's kind of like if it if you earn
our attention you'll get
but i do i hear what you're saying like
we're we're programming
the youth to just have zero attention
well we're talking about the algorithm
earlier all these things it's all about
like
instant satisfaction i mean think of a
show like family guy which is like kind
of groundbreaking
because they were like we're not going
to have a plot it's really just going to
be the job
yeah yeah that's true yeah they cut the
fat and it was great
i mean i love family guy i think it's
still on
i don't know who knows i don't want to
watch his tv anymore but uh isn't that
crazy
that's crazy we spent our whole lives
trying to get on tv and now we're like
youtube is better than if we had a
special on fox of course i mean i could
watch an animal attack then i can cut to
like
the playoffs in the 88 and then i could
cut to uh a
fist fight in the street then you can
cut through like oh look at this johnny
carson set with rob
hilarious if that was the actual that
was cable you're just like you change
the channels two bums beating the [ __ ]
out of everything
yeah that'd be great and then porn is
right there so like
it's just everything you want in any
genre any
art form it's all right there yeah
nostalgia whatever you want
so youtube is always the winner for me
youtube is incredible i i try to like
i should watch hacks i might watch that
give it a shot give it a shot it's it's
two episodes in
i think they're like waiting for more to
come out everybody uh dan pearlman and
kevin is over sean
on a show time called flatbush
misdemeanors and it's getting good
reviews
i want to see that too i like both of
them a lot so all right i'll check that
out
check that out in show time because i
hear good things i love iso i've that's
uh i've gotten drunk with him a few
times he's a good we were just
in a bathroom together at the stand and
we had some good laughs
but uh pearlman's a good egg promo's got
a great line
uh about uh his friend i don't know i
mean i shouldn't give away his material
but he's got it
it's an older joke his friend's like i
like to date girls
who are still pretty without makeup and
he's like
that's not that doesn't make you noble
you know
you're basically saying like oh i only
date god's home runs
which is such a great line that's great
god's home runs
god's home run yeah so uh yeah
check that out and uh we're on the road
we're back before we go oh geez yeah
let's do a bit
i have a whole cop chunk that's hitting
but i have one or two lines i need to
get on on board
all right hit me baby part of it i don't
know if i'll remember it but part of it
is uh
you know the people i this is how i kind
of started and this didn't really hit
but i think there's some potential here
there's a thing on you know citizen's
app
yes yes there was a thing there was a
thing on it in california
this guy was accused of starting the
wildfires with a 30 000
reward and uh
it was up for like 15 hours and it turns
out he didn't do it
and as it's almost like the liberals who
were like defund the police who are also
like
what if we were the police that's so
true it didn't really hit but i think
it's like a fun
premier so i started doing things like i
think they should have to be the police
for a year the far left that would be
perfect just a year of them like you
know pulling you over and you're like
was i speeding like no but
uh we found a tweet of yours from 2008
and you're like that's
great is that against that's the end is
that against the lawn you're like no we
just wanted to know
we just wanted you to know that we know
and you're like yeah
that's great so then i want to do a
thing i had other angles with it like uh
you know i'm trying to think of it like
uh
you're under like you have the right to
remain silent but if you do want to
speak we're willing to listen cause
you've been a marginalized voice and
we're aware of that
right my cut that might do one about um
it feels like if they were black they
wouldn't get pulled over hey that guy's
speeding yeah he's blessed let's let it
go let's let it go do they plant
evidence on jew
on jews and white people they're like
or like uh you know another angle was
like uh this this hit this line hit
where i was like
uh you know uh it's kind of like
i feel like he's guilty and you're like
well the evidence says he's not you're
like well you have your truth and i have
mine
oh that's good that's good yeah
this is my truth this is my truth yeah
well we need a judge to come in
no no this is my this is we've already
this is how i feel
yeah yeah you can't argue with how i
feel so then the last part this bombed i
think this is funny but this bombed i
say
you know yeah cops make horrible
decisions but at least most of them are
split second decisions
like liberals make bad decisions that
last decades
cops are like cops are like hope that's
a hope that's really a gun
liberals are like two to the woody allen
again
[Laughter]
really yeah zilch that's i guess i guess
people aren't thinking about woody allen
as much as we are
but that's great also cops
the thing about cops is yeah like they
put a guy in jail he does the time
they get out with with the the liberals
it's like
you're just [ __ ] forever we just hate
you and you're
yeah you're just stuck there's no
there's like it's funny the same people
that are like
this person deserves a second chance or
like [ __ ] that guy forever
yeah exactly where's the second chance
somebody had a great line uh it was like
wokeness is like a religion except
there's no forgiveness
yeah that's great that's a great line
that's heavy damn
but uh you know that's great that's it's
a hard bit because it's
there's nothing tangible there you're
just going all off of
basically like kind of the war we're
living in now yeah that's a great bit
though
it's just fun because i do think that
like
a lot of the fun like look i identify
with a lot of liberal politics but a lot
of
a lot of progressives will do [ __ ] where
they don't ever put themselves
in the other person's shoes yes and it's
like which is the definition of
open-mindedness and
consideration compassion well you see
people like like white women yelling and
like there was one of like her like pony
in the black cop's face that went viral
and it's like
that guy might know what it's like right
he might
black lives matter he's like i'm black
i'm a cop i might have my foot in both
yeah i might actually have an
understanding
i don't know i think they get so swept
up and like the activism and saving the
world and everything that like
you don't realize you're yelling at this
guy but it's not real activism you
posted a [ __ ] black square on
instagram you didn't do anything like
there's no
i even think about this a lot like i
went to a couple protests and they're
not
people just want it to be a thing but
it's like real protests were unsafe
yeah like martin luther king and like
like you were marching in mississippi
that was unsafe
yeah you're [ __ ] marching in the
suburbs right
right and there's a panera bread right
next to where you're marching
you're getting a bowl right after this
[ __ ] yeah and when you break it all down
a lot of this is for you for sure ladies
you wanted a picture for your photo you
want people to know and look look i'm
not saying your intentions aren't good
i'm not saying
that it's good to feel that people
deserve equal rights obviously and that
like your heart's in the right place
but there was an annoying type of person
that
is like i don't want to get political on
here because it's like a fun drinking
show but when people are like defund the
police it's like we'll come up with a
[ __ ] solution then
exactly what's the solution we all have
guns
right i can't drive a car i feel like
this isn't gonna work out well everyone
with a [ __ ] firearm
and then ironically the people who say
defund the police are very police-like
they're telling you what you can do what
you can't say what you can't do and
you're like
he's like a cop i'm scared of you like i
thought
you hated these people and you're one of
the it's it's the gay senator who's
closeted and he's like
we got to stop these homos and you're
like you're you're gay dude
this is the this is your weird
overcompensation it's the same [ __ ]
right and both sides have [ __ ] up the
extremes are all
over exactly most people just are are
decent but yeah
certain things obviously have to be
corrected but i look i i just think
there's
just don't make it about you you know to
help people
i like i like progress i want to i want
people to be equal and
and move on and all this but like this
is more for
a lot of people it's more for them than
it is for the actual cause
they're tweeting about [ __ ] but they're
not actually living that [ __ ]
yeah i think there's a disconnect with
social media yeah i think like
you're you're a different person behind
the keyboards it is like
a doll for a lot of it not everybody a
lot of people it's for show
oh yeah like i mean you're not showing
your low points on there you're not
leaving the abortion clinic like selfie
you're doing it at [ __ ]
you're showing yourself leaving like
cool places you're right right you know
what i mean
you're not showing yourself at your
lowest you're showing yourself you like
you there it's there is virtue signaling
obviously
yeah it comes down to perception you
know i want to be perceived this way
yeah and that's what we do online i mean
i want to
be perceived as funny so i only post
jokes
i do not post any and people like why
are you being quiet about this i'm like
i'm quiet about everything
because i'm i'm a comedian and i'm
keeping it jokey
i have a lot of new bits it's funny i
have a new bit also about like how
p i saw a guy in a t-shirt that says
[ __ ] racism i was like damn we have to
wear shirts now
it's like i can't just feel that in my
heart it's like i say you don't see me
walking around in my islamophobes can
suck my nut t-shirt yeah
so the angle i'm doing is like like i
just want to start walking around in
like a in a
t-shirt that says [ __ ] baby rapist and
people are just like
like why are you wearing them like are
you are you pro baby
well i'm trying to raise awareness so
it's like there was like an obviousness
to this and like a
yeah there was like a virtue signaling
element where it's like most people
know a lot of it's like structures that
need to be changed most people are i
think good
i agree i agree completely it's just
this gooey middle
yeah you know where some people are too
far this way some people are too far
that way most people are just somewhere
in the middle just being quiet
it's like the quiet guy on the train
we're like census workers
in the way that we because we're like we
meet so many people on the road
right and i do feel like i meet so many
people i'm like this is a good person
this is like i can tell that decent
human being
like so many people i met after the
shows and youtube like these are like
calm kind of humble like kind people
yeah and then
you know you see people on social media
and you're like where the [ __ ] did that
go
i know i know social media is like when
someone does a line and
a couple of whiskeys you know you're
like this should not be
what you're putting out there but the
bad [ __ ] gets the likes of the bad so
people are kind of like
whether you like it or not it's almost
like you get fed when you behave badly
yes yes i mean look at the the headlines
like
stop asian hate is the hashtag so like
the
news will only show asian people getting
beat up but like a bunch of people get
beat up
my friend's a cop he'll be like oh yeah
bunch of people got beat up that day but
they show the asian one
just because it's a hashtag you're like
i don't know if that's
that's not good well they go with
whatever the story is they go if they
have like i mean
[ __ ] man there's like if if you're
outraged about it that's what they're
running that weep because that's the
news now it used to be the news and now
it's literally like this will get the
click
yep yep like look at every new york post
tweet you're like this
every single one of these is shameless
clickbait
yes of course like i said the other day
and it was like
ben we meet the real benefit like why
this is more
yeah forget the forget the old benefit
i'm like i'm trying to forget but you
[ __ ] post it every day
right and that's the irony is they want
bad [ __ ] to happen like you act like you
hate bad [ __ ] but you actually
love it it's it's like when uh bill bird
does the
grammys and everybody's like bill burr's
a racist and then people go well
actually his wife's black and they go
whatever like what do you mean whatever
i thought you hated racism
there's you were wrong whatever happened
to someone just not being your type of
person
well that too but it's like well i can
be like yeah i mean like i love
billboard but maybe some maybe he's not
for some people and that's okay but
why do you have to jump to [ __ ]
racist i don't get that because they
they but the irony is they want it to be
racist but it's all good in the end
because it's all just
clicks for bill and it's all just i mean
look it's annoying but the end of the
day like
this is more fans are finding bill burr
i hope so but yeah i read every one of
those [ __ ] things because i'm a
psycho
and you are a psycho something's wrong
with you to read this i read all because
i want to know where people's heads at
and i'm like
this is crazy like you really think he's
a race then then they show a picture of
his wife and he's like
they're like ah who cares about that he
could still be right you're like jesus
what is wrong with you psychos but
but it's like kind of like are you are
you battling real hate
are you battling real intolerance or
you're just sitting behind a keyboard
yeah and stirring [ __ ] up yeah twitter
is like a stock market for fake activism
oh asian hate's up this week let's go
they're all looking at the big screen
stop asian hate let's go let's move yeah
yeah yeah what about the clits getting
cut off ah
that's old that's out go with the asian
you know
they're in a room some guy takes him to
lunch he's a martini
we get a lot of asian hate tweets going
i get three asian tweets before dinner
uh
work out at six a.m
not everyone's gonna get that but if you
got it that was dead on
you know you haven't seen wolf of wall
street coming i love it give me a joke
all right oh man i uh i feel bad cause i
i'm
this sounds [ __ ] but i've gotten a
bunch of jokes from this show to work
so i don't want to do one that works
same no dude
i feel like i feel the same way and i do
get the compliment from people after the
show sometimes like
it's cool to hear you and mark say that
and then see that yeah work so
exactly i'm glad that's kind of the
point of the show so i'm glad that
totally point to that segment at least
all right all right
so uh this is a joke i'm working on
about uh it's actually about
similar to twitter so it's kind of in
the same vein but
one of the cool things about animals is
first of all they can't tweet
and animals have horrible lives and they
never bring it up
like if animals could tweet it would put
all our [ __ ] in perspective wow
you know like uh you know if a zebra in
africa was like a
you know finally found water
haven't haven't had water in a week and
then a crocodile at my only child
fml you know you've got to do a some
line i don't know if you already do this
with some line about
her children are in cages hashtag
chickens or something oh
that's good that's good i like that
and then i have this whole thing about
how we don't realize but one of the best
qualities of animals
they don't [ __ ] they don't complain
like you watch planet earth some zebra
is running away from four lines they
bite him on the ass they pull him down
by his neck
and then he kicks one of the he manages
to get away and that's just it
there's no blog there's no press
conference app there's no scene of the
zebra going well that was a [ __ ] hate
crime jesus christ
did you see that and uh it's because i'm
interracial you know
so that's it that hits yeah yeah i like
too it's like i
my flight gets delayed 30 minutes i'm
like hashtag [ __ ] delta
forever exactly meanwhile these people
like watch their families dies and
they're like
tomorrow will be better i don't know
right yeah they're just trying to
survive they're trying to get through it
and there's
zero obviously they can't talk but
there's zero like
remora i mean you just you just move on
with your life you know there's
something about having to survive
like we create these lists like set
status system like
you know you're on your flight you're
like annoyed you don't get upgraded
right
that doesn't exist in the animal world
no it's just
[ __ ] sink or swim yeah there's
something like very
you're going to be less depressed when
your life is that simple probably
completely completely and us complaining
is
a privilege we don't realize it like we
have yelp we have
segments on this show we
complain and it's funny it's like it's
therapeutic
like i i complain on this show and i'm
like i feel better yeah
yeah yeah and they they can't do that
animals actually yelp
they yell for help like they're like hey
we
tried that no i just thought of that we
have a site called yelp we're like it's
drafty in here
you know don't come to this restaurant
enchiladas were only okay
yeah their yelp is i i lost my leg
right exactly and they they press on
so i lost my leg two and a half stars
i like the the kids in cages chickens
okay that's that was something because
it's like we complained about kids in
cages but it's like they're literally in
cages because they're about to die
right right yeah they're like we're
shooting on hotels they're literally
like oh did you not like a holiday inn i
was in a slaughterhouse
yes that's great there was a pube in the
shower
animal's like i eat tight fur carcasses
whatever
whatever it takes we were in the hotel
and devito said to me is like man
there's dogs in this hotel i change
rooms because i i think i have fleas
whoa
oh please we're in a [ __ ] hotel with
fleas
jesus fleabag motel [ __ ] fleabags
that's a little bit like i've had fleas
before i'm like who are you
i've had fleas you had fleas well my dog
had fleas as a kid then i got fleas and
it's a nightmare
yeah it didn't sound good no i think i'm
good bed bugs is still worse bed bugs is
[ __ ] that is like nom vet [ __ ] you're
up at 3am like
they're coming after me you know you're
having like like
flashbacks and night terrors i love it
all right we got to wrap this up we got
to wrap it up i'm going back here uh
albany funny bone this weekend man
friday saturday
atlantic city tampa uh side splitters
raleigh a lot of great [ __ ] coming to
valley north carolina samurail.com
shows oh that's a good sight i've never
heard that i've never heard that i've
heard live or
comedy but shows is good yeah man
virginia beach funny bone never been you
ever done that one
i haven't everyone thinks that my stew
story is from virginia beach
i changed the city for the joke but it's
it's a similar city
i've never been to virginia beach yeah
i'm coming with fat chriselle
uh that should be fun orlando florida
let's sell that puppy out san antonio
helium those breakfast tacos man oh yeah
love it love antonio's got some [ __ ]
great mexican great mexican food
great alamo portland helium uh funny
bone syracuse
oh that's going to hurt toledo funny
bone houston improv
philly buffalo dayton so yeah
the the the calendar is full oh i got
like nashville and zany's coming oh
you gotta go to that that's a hot that's
one of the fun clubs
yeah tell lucy i said hello a lot of
great clubs coming up
uh if i forgot anything all right i feel
bad matt's gonna get divorced if we
don't wrap up
oklahoma city coming up in july matt
madison
great why are you doing madison that's
one of the greats
one of the greats i'm fired up guys keep
uh keep listening subscribe to our
patreon we might be drunk pod
yes patreon.com we might be drunk pod
email us your peeves your wrecks
all that [ __ ] your jokes anything
your drinks
uh we might be drunk pod at gmail.com
yes love you guys thanks for listening
thank you